And the correct answer is n over n - 1.
We can see this just with looking at the single example
because of the other options, the only other one that yields 2 is n.
That would imply that the correction factor grows linearly with the amount of data.
So if we have a million data points,
our variance would need to be somehow multiplied by a million
to come up with the actual variance.
That doesn't correspond well with intuition
because, presumably, as we have bigger and bigger samples,
we should be getting closer to reality,
although that's not a true proof, but you can prove it to yourself
by trying this out on some larger sample sizes.